-Thank you so much
for coming on the show, buddy.
I appreciate it.
-No problem.
-Kevin, I hear you have a game
that you want to play.
-Yes, man, I do have a game
that I want to play.
It's actually one of the games
from my show,
"Celebrity Game Face,"
that we were talking about,
and it's a game called
"Fill in the Blank." Okay?
♪♪
All right, so, look,
this is a game that tests
how well two people
know each other.
Jimmy, I feel like you and I,
we know each other very well.
-Long time.
-So I'll ask a personal question
and then, you should have
a whiteboard in front of you.
-Mm-hmm. Yes, I do.
-You'll write down how you think
the other person will answer,
right?
And then, at the end of it,
we'll say our own actual answer,
and if it's what we wrote,
if it matches, we get a point.
It make sense?
-Love it.
Very simple.
-Yeah.
We're gonna be besties
after this.
-All right, I think so.
Okay. You ready?
The first question is, if I
could change one thing about me,
it would be my...
-Okay. And this is...
-Think about it.
-I'm answering for you?
-Yeah.
And I'm answering for you.
Okay?
All right?
I got it.
I got you.
Okay.
There we go.
-So if I could change
one thing about Kevin Hart,
yes, about yourself...
-Yeah.
-...Kevin Hart,
so I'm answering for you, yeah.
So what would be your answer?
-Okay. You ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-3, 2...
My nose.
Yeah.
-Oh.
-What'd you say?
Size of my -- no.
No, Jimmy.
My nose.
That didn't -- my nose.
-Sorry.
You would change your nose?
-Well, just, you know,
not change it,
but I'm just saying, like,
there's times
when it flares a little bit.
-[ Laughs ]
-It gets a little --
It gets a little excessive.
I thought that you thought
that I was probably gonna say
my height, and that's not --
I wouldn't change my height.
I'm fine with that.
Right?
That's no points.
-I would never do that.
So no points for that.
All right, I just took a guess.
-I thought you knew me.
And I've complained
about my nose to you before.
There was times where I was
like, "I'm smelling everything.
I just wish I had
a little less nostril."
Remember I told you that?
I thought you'd remember that.
-What do you think I would
change about myself?
-If I could write it down?
You want me to write down
what you would change
about yourself?
-Yeah.
-Easy. Easy.
-Really?
-Easy. Yes.
-Change about myself...
-Got it.
-1, 2, 3.
-Forehead.
-I'm too nice.
-Your forehead.
No?
Wait a second, Jimmy.
[ Buzzer ]
No, Jimmy.
-Why do you think
I want to change my forehead?
-Because it's so big.
I thought that you didn't --
It's a lot of space.
-Same size as your forehead.
-Yeah, but we got two
different-shaped heads.
You got a lot of travel space.
-I'm Irish.
-Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I thought you wanted
to condense it a little bit.
-I'd never heard of someone
condensing their forehead.
-All right. Well, then,
maybe I guessed that wrong.
I assumed, because of
that space in there,
that you would've wanted
to take it out.
It's like closing up a highway.
-This --
-[ Laughs ]
-This is...
This is the last question.
This one is for all the marbles.
This is to say
are we best friends
or we not best friends, okay?
-Okay.
-We're gonna get this one.
-Yep.
-Go for it.
-All right. Are you ready?
-Yeah.
-I have a question.
The person I would want
to play me in a movie
about my life is...
Oh, this is good.
This is good.
All right? And this is me.
Come on.
You got to think about this.
You got to really
think about this, okay?
-Mm-hmm.
-All right. You ready?
-To play you in a movie.
I know who it is.
Count of three -- 1, 2, 3.
Webster.
Emmanuel Lewis.
What?
-No, man.
Denzel.
-Dude, well, Emmanuel --
I'm just sayin' --
-Denzel.
No, man.
What are you --
-Dude, he's funny.
He can act.
He can do anything.
I guessed, yes, Denzel, as well.
-Denzel, man.
-That's what I meant to write.
That's what I meant to write.
-Yeah, I need somebody
that can really grasp
my death and my life
in a performance, man.
-I love you, buddy.
Thank you for playing this.
That is how you play
"Fill in my Blank."
-Yes.
-Give it up for Kevin Hart.
His show, "Celebrity Game Face"
is on Thursday at 10:00 p.m.
on the E! Network.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Great to see you, bud.